an experiment that was done a long time
ago now probably 20 years ago by Brown
and shuet where they took a cohort of
adult males who had alcohol use disorder
Al alcoholism who also met criteria for
major depressive disorder they put them
in a hospital where they had no access
to alcohol for one month they did not
give them any treatment for depression
at all not no Psychotherapy Nom meds
nothing at the end of that time period
80% of those individuals no longer met
criter IA for major depressive episode
so simply by stopping
drinking their symptoms of depression
resolved and we see that again and again
and again in clinical care another
phrase you mentioned that's cool is that
you said hey I'm not asking you to go
live in a cave for 30 days
now would living in a cave for 30 days
be salutary or deleterious now the
reason I would think it would be
deleterious and you can tell me if I'm
incorrect is that it's solving something
that's quote unquote extreme like an
addiction with something else that's
extreme and so then when they come back
into the real world well they may have
solved their problem in a cave but then
they deal with all the triggers of the
real
world so some people when they when
they're going through some let's say
mental health issues they feel like what
I need to do I need to go to Brazil and
take iasa I need to do something extreme
I need to go live in the woods for seven
days
alone is it replacing something that's
let me rephrase that is it replacing
something intense with something else
that's intense or not maybe it's okay
you could you could do that in fact
that's better go live in a cave for 30
days you know I think there are many
paths to the top of the mountain um you
know it could be that for some
individuals being in something like a
cave for 30 days might actually be
helpful I think I was using that more
metaphorically though
to um talk a little bit about you know
how the the the term dopamine fasting is
often used here in Silicon Valley that
you have kind of CEO exec types who
literally do go into a kind of a cave
for a week typically and then talk about
how when they come out after that kind
of sensory deprivation they experience
incredible Euphoria by very simple
things just the beauty of a flower uh
you know a glass of water whatever you
know
and I think that that's not what we talk
that's not what we're recommending to
our patients because our patients are
coming to us you know with mental health
issues addiction and other mental health
issues we would never recommend that
folks in that fragile and vulnerable
state go into a cave um what we might
recommend is that they go to a 30-day
residential Rehabilitation facility
where they don't have access to alcohol
but where they're surrounded by people
with whom they can make positive
therapeutic connections where they might
get prescribed some medications where
they're in group in individual
therapy but nonetheless the the sort of
you know Silicon Valley dopamine fast
the point there is I think a broader one
which is to say we live in a society
today which is very very noisy we are
constantly
overstimulated constantly being asked to
react to enormous quantities a flooding
really of information and as a result
our brains are stressed you know we are
we are kind of in this constant state of
hyperarousal and because of that I the
point is I think we could all benefit
from in different ways kind of quieting
our lives for a period of time or doing
a fast from something that we consume
more than we would like and this is the
approach that we take it's not that it's
not really realistic frankly for most
people to even go way to like a retreat
or something like that most people just
have to keep going with their lives but
what they can do is identify one or two
substances or behaviors that they use in
an outof control compulsive and harmful
way that they would like to manage
better in their lives and focus on
giving that up for 30 days and then
seeing what the impact is so it's really
an experiment it's like you know life is
one big experiment why not experiment
with these everyday behaviors and habits
one of the ways to figure out how a
system works is to change a variable in
that system and and and you know record
what happens and so that's essentially
what what we're asking people do the
experiment eliminate alcohol as long as
you're not at risk for life-threatening
withdrawal right eliminate cannabis
eliminate pornography and compulsive
masturbation eliminate video games
eliminate romance novels see what
happens it can be very instructive for
me it certainly was I experienced actual
withdrawal where I had intense insomnia
in the first 10 to 14 days that's what
we would expect people in those first 10
to 14 days whether they're giving up
sugar or giving up Canabis or romance
novels they it's hard but by weeks three
and four what I experienced and what
most of our patients experience is the
craving eventually subsides the mood
gets better the anxiety lessens there's
a sort of quiet quieting and centering
that happens there's an ability to be
more present because we're not con
stantly looking forward to some future
reward right because if you think about
it if you organize your whole day around
getting past right now you and I talking
to each other so that I can get to you
know whatever my Netflix binge or my
romance novel or my whatever you know
then it's harder to be fully present in
the moment but if we give up the kinds
of rewards that we're all using to shape
our day we can be fully more present and
people talk about that a lot I'm able to
be more present for my spouse more
present for my children more present for
other tasks that I have to do so this is
the kind of thing that we we ask it
sounds like the first two weeks will be
the most difficult for sure what should
people expect you mentioned
insomnia and what should people do in
order to get over some of the common
side effects or detrimental effects or
whatever we want to call them so if one
is an AA I imagine that they can call
someone you have a partner now this many
people who are listening they have
people in their lives but they're alone
in this regard what are they to
do well I do think it is very important
to stay connected to other people
ideally you would maybe do do the
exercise together with somebody else so
you're encouraging each other helping
each other remain accountable this can
be in the context of a mutual help group
like Alcoholics Anonymous or cannabis
Anonymous or sexaholics Anonymous or or
just with a you know loving partner or a
family member or friend who knows what
you're going through maybe shares that
problem and you can do it together um if
you're doing it on your own you can have
a trusted individual make make let
people know you know that you're doing
it so that they can help support you in
other ways even if they are not
themselves engaging in in the dopamine
fast activity um I think learning how to
just sit with the uncomfortable emotions
without reaching for our maladaptive uh
you know High dopamine reward um and
observing how that craving can come and
go and and and that we can endure it
this is sometimes called surfing urge
surfing that it can sweep over us like a
wave but doesn't last forever that can
be empowering for people um creating
alternate activities now one danger with
alternate activities is sometimes we
replace one reward with another right so
instead instead of reading a romance
novel I'm going to have a cookie but the
problem with that is cookies are also
highly potent and I might end up you
know getting addicted to cookies or
compulsively eating cookies or just
gaining weight which is not something I
would necessarily want to do um so
sometimes we recommend actually
something called hormesis hormesis is
Greek for to set in motion it's about
how we can use painful stimuli to
actually upregulate uh dopamine and
other neurotransmitters so this would be
things like exercising or um having an
ice cold water bath or intermittent
fasting or other things that are
actually more challenging than the the
pain of that craving or withdrawal and
that's another thing that people can try
you mentioned in one of your talks that
there's a misconception about the
present moment that we think of it as a
blissful state but rather it's
characterized by a painful tedium can
you outline that and help people to help
set expectations correctly to guide them
through this boredom that they'll
experience when they no longer have this
addiction or when it's interrupting
their thoughts and they have to not
follow it yeah so yeah let me like
qualify that that quote a little bit I
will say that being present in the
moment can be wonderful but I know that
you know in my youth I would often you
know hear people like Ram da say be here
now and things like that and and I
always tried to do that and found that
that was intensely uncom able for me
because being in my own thoughts and in
my own body I didn't want to be there
that wasn't a that wasn't a particularly
a delightful place I have a lot of
anxious ruminations and things I worry
about and guilt I feel and you know
regrets and on and on so I I kept I
always thought well you know I must not
be doing the being in the moment
correctly because if I were uh wouldn't
I experience some kind of levitating
Bliss because that seems to be what
people are promising it really took
until midlife for me to realize oh be
here now means being in my mind and in
my body even if it's not a particularly
comfortable place and even if I find
myself you know circling the drain on
repetitive ruminative thoughts um if I
stay there long enough and you know
breathe or do whatever other meditation
exercises um to help with grounding and
centering eventually um those kinds of
thoughts sort of lose their potency and
and or instead help inform decision
making and and moving forward you know
that voice of our own Consciousness
telling us things we need to do and
listening to it and saying oh I should
probably do that if I'm My Mind Is
Telling Me enough times I I should do
that should say sorry or right letter
things like that instead of constantly
trying to distract ourselves from
ourselves if you enjoyed that clip then
the full podcast is out right now you
can click around here enjoy subscribe to
theories of everything to get notified
of upcoming podcasts as there are new
full length podcasts every week on the
topics of mathematics physics
Consciousness Free Will and
AI